[Musique]
cyrille melchior président du
département convié tous les principaux
et gestionnaires des collèges publics et
privés de lille ce mardi 25 septembre
une rencontre conviviale et détendue qui
s'est déroulée dans les jardins de la
villa du département
si on veut lutter contre les exclusions
il faut donner les meilleures chances à
nos enfants aux enfants de la réunion et
cela passe par un système éducatif
performant et si le système éducatif de
terre performant le devons avoir des
locaux de qualité des établissements de
qualité c'est pour cela que nous avons
lancé un programme de réhabilitation des
établissements siens nous soutenons
l'éducation à travers plein de projets
il y va de la promotion des jeunes
réunionnais une matinée d'échangés
l'occasion de rappeler les grands axes
de la politique éducative menée par le
département il ya le projet de
construction de reconstruction et à les
projets de réhabilitation de rénovation
en tous les cas ce que je peux dire en
un
c'est que le département avec le comment
la volonté de le président cyrille
melchior
c'est de faire en sorte qu'ils aient un
mieux-vivre ponote jeunesse réunionnaise
ou au milieu
en fait dans l'éducation même et nous y
apportons notre pierre est qu au combien
utile pour beaucoup d'entre eux le
département un partenaire indispensable
960 emplois sont financés par la
collectivité en faveur des collèges
le montant total de la masse salariale
représente 44 millions d'euros
ajoutez à cela les 41 millions d'euros
pour l'entretien l'aménagement la
réhabilitation et la construction des
collèges
le département est un bien évidemment un
partout un partenaire privilégié un on
ne pourrait pas fonctionner si nous
n'avions pas la collectivité donc
c'était intéressant aussi par exemple
belle de mettre en valeur ce aujourd'hui
toutes les actions d'où ce partenariat
constructif au service des élèves
c'est dans ce même bonne initiative mais
c'est nécessaire que sa ville et qu'elle
n'est jamais tout seul
elle travaille avec mains de partenariat
et le département était un des parents
est un partenaire important pas
seulement pour les collèges d'ailleurs
mais pour d'autres aspects de
l'éducation qui concerne le social la
santé donc des rencontres régulières et
des comptes des rencontres qui sont
positives et qu'il faut que les gens se
parlent
c'est une très bonne chose la matinée
s'est achevée par une remise de
médailles à quatre collégiens ayant
accompli des actes d'héroïsme ou de
solidarité
[Musique]